we're following Glaser three orphans and
really strong relationships yeah and I
hope people can relate to those themes
as well as all the exciting things like
the monsters and the magic and yeah yeah
it's got everything
do you have what it takes
you can outrun destiny alright ladies so
my first question is this show has been
so kept under wraps the fandom is so
rabid how hard was it to keep things so
secretive oh yeah angry just so
enthusiastic about the show it was
difficult but also like not much yeah I
think the word spoiler kind of scared us
to be honest I so do my friends but I
mean it went in one ear out the other
because they don't have a clue what I'm
on about yeah I don't know worries yeah
did you feel a sense of excitement to
finally get to talk about it though I
mean it's finally hot an exam I worked
on for so long we are nervous oh yeah
yeah I am I am I'm very anxious
obviously but but that's a personal fear
like I'm just really excited to see how
the fans react and and what everyone's
response is to it okay yeah I hope they
really enjoy it because I love what's
going to it did you feel that pressure
of the fans of these hardcore fans who
have loved these stories for so long of
course going into it you think oh
there's people who are already very
attached to a certain creation in their
mind of this character but as actors we
just have to go in and do our absolute
best to portray the roles and that's
kind of all we can do and hope that
people like what we've done so I think
that's the best way to look at it if you
were to give someone who's not a fan
just a quick explanation here's what my
character is what would you say about
each of your characters I would say
series of princess she's the princess of
sintra she's stubborn
feisty determined but also has a gentle
side to her as well yennefer is a
sorceress again very stubborn as she
doesn't pay no for an answer
and she's one of the most powerful mages
in the continent I love the power that
women have on this show what was it like
for you guys to film some
those battle scenes the swordplay all
that how fun are scary was it yeah it
was scary I was just I wanted more I
loved it I wanted more training and I
wish we had more time to do those yeah I
loves it yeah yeah I mean I'm just dying
to have some fighting because I don't
really have any yeah you're like I'm
ready yeah I'm ready season two exactly
of course I'm coming to do these
interviews and I have to tell you a lot
of people in my office are like Henry is
so beautiful I just want to stare at him
was there any element of that unsaid
most I own me oh yeah everything Henry
were like you are gorgeous
yeah no every time I saw Henry was in a
white wig and I it was actually we went
from a meal I when he was when he was a
girl and I couldn't shocked cuz I only
ever seen him as garel like literally
yes the physical transformations that
everybody goes through the costumes all
that I mean so much fun was there did
you take anything from set that you
wanted to keep his little memento and
how did it feel for you yeah watch Lee I
remember I did take one of the dresses
from there
did you hate it until now
I took a dress yeah yeah I took one of
my dresses because anyway that everyone
knows that I wanted to take my cloak buy
a dress I took the yennefer like a
Vermeer chair yeah
oh I love that I have to ask you I don't
think a fantasy series can be made today
without getting some Game of Thrones
comparisons they are happening online
how do you guys feel about the
comparisons that are being made is there
anything that you feel in your mind
about it or want to say to it
it's just flattering written because
that's obviously a very successful show
but a lot of people who are very
invested in it and you know be great if
we could have that same kind of thing
that same run
yeah what would you tell people about
why they have to watch this show why
because it's not it's not just got all
the brilliant fantasy elements
fantastical elements to this genre but
like the fantasy genre baits it's got a
lot of heart and like it's you know
we're following the lives of three
orphans and the really strong
relationships yeah and I hope people can
relate to those themes as well as all
the exciting things like the monsters
and the magic and yeah yeah it's got
everything yeah
and against the powerful women I did
like that I was like oh the women are
right in this battle that has their own
story uh-huh we got a woman leading the
battle right on the right off
[Music]